Albert Stillman was buried here barely
an hour ago his family says he died from
covert 19 they wanted to bury him at
their home and soon duza in rural
Eastern Cape but lockdown restrictions
mean this is his final resting place not
in a cemetery stared a solitary grave in
an open field to comply with
restrictions just a few people attended
the funeral the freedoms of tradition
and custom replaced by social distancing
rules they've never showed any respect
to my father even when he worked at the
mine he got nothing he died as a poor
man now he has been buried like garbage
because of the corona it is really
really painful the local council has his
33 people in this village have tested
positive for coronavirus but he thinks
the number is far higher we don't have
resources whereby people can test so
people just undermine it as a simple flu
they take it as a simple flu then after
a long time or after somebody's death
then it's right by they recognize this
is code 19 there is concern that
funerals which usually attract hundreds
of people are helping to spread the
virus at the cemetery outside the small
town of Berkeley East police Keep Watch
ensuring there are no more than 50
people attending the burial is short and
people leave quickly the eastern cape is
large much of it rural and people don't
live as close together compared to other
places so the spread of the corona virus
has surprised experts who were worried
this province may be south africa's next
epicenter some estimates say that as
many as 80% of the people here may get
covered 19 but in rural towns like this
one medical facilities are understaffed
and under resourced this hospital and
stack spread was closed when we filmed
him staff had protested against the lack
of personal protective equipment
shutting some of the units
authorities had restricted travel
between provinces to curb the outbreak
and permits are required to make a
journey here people are screened for the
virus we passed through the site twice
in two days
on the second day we were not screened
at all along with dozens of other
passengers in vehicles passing through
temperature checks and collecting
contact details only resumed once we
began filming while the number of covert
19 infections grow the government is
still easing some of its restrictions
and here in one of South Africa's
poorest provinces inconsistent plans and
policies may add to the rising numbers
Fermi tamela al Jazeera Eastern Cape
South Africa